I want to say sorry in advance I'm kind
of sick so I I might kaufe lot which is
why this video will be heavily edited
and small announcement I remember I used
to have free resumes I would share my
resume and my resume template my cover
letters and my cover letter templates to
you guys
that link has been broken for the past
six months but I finally fixed them so
there during the description now so you
guys can check that out
sorry it took so long but alright let's
start the video okay so the first story
I want to talk about is that there was
someone who had a Google offer for two
hundred and seventy seven thousand
dollars total compensation at Google and
I thought that was pretty cool and I was
extremely jealous but this story was on
blind in case you don't know what
blindness is this anonymous forum it's
kind of like reddit but for work I
stumbled upon this post on blind
it's about this person who got a Google
offer and he said it was thanks to blind
you know he came from a Cs background at
a no-name public university apparently
and he had three years of experience and
a mid-sized tech company making a
hundred fifty K okay and then after his
hard work interviewing what happened is
he ended up with two hundred and seventy
seven thousand dollars total
compensation as an elf for at Google
if this isn't the American dream I don't
know what is now the threat was huge as
you can see there were so many people
congratulating him and asking him
follow-up questions blah blah blah
the threat is definitely worth reading
for people who want to interview for
Google cuz he gives actually a lot of
tips but I don't care about that I read
it because I never had anyone
congratulate me for my job
so I kind of pretended that was me yeah
anyways let's see how he did it I think
that's what you guys care about so
apparently the first thing he did is he
read let's see elements of programming
interviews which is a book it's oh he
bought the java version he said that I
wouldn't have even heard about this book
without seeing it mention on blind mmm
what a brown-noser good book though but
um I actually used the Python version
because I'm a snake and then after that
he leaked coded classic classic he said
I don't think I would have done as much
leak code as I did if I wasn't stressed
so much on line grows man said why don't
you just go marry blind if you like
blind so much man I hate this guy
anyways and then the third thing he did
he also said that he used algo expert io
a site where you can practice coding
interviews along with video explanations
now I'm kidding he no he he didn't he
didn't use I'll go expert but he could
have and it probably would have been
worth it just saying so for leak code
apparently he did 130 questions
30 easy 50 medium and 20 hard like mine
and then when he interviewed at Google
he said that he had six total interviews
one phone call which was a 45 minutes
and then five on-site which were also
all 45 minutes and one of them he said
was a behavioral interview and yeah
apparently Google does that now and I
heard that they call it a [ __ ] Lee
interview yeah they want to know how
googly you are if you don't know what
googly means for them it means it just
means that you're not a jerk if you're a
googly then a meter
jerk so they're just making sure of that
for example if you're subscribed to this
channel your googly and if you talk [ __ ]
about me because of all my ads then that
is not googly yeah and he said the rest
of the interviews were all pure coding
no system design questions after he
passed all the interviews for the
negotiating part he said I received
three competing offers of about 250,000
but thanks to blind thanks to blind
I knew Google could pay more so he had
an initial offer from Google for
$250,000
which was already pretty good by itself
and then he used all those $250,000
offers to try to boost him up so I think
he did some negotiating back and forth
between the companies and eventually Oh
actually wait let me he actually lied
saying that they paid 270 thousand
instead of 250 thousand they said that
the offers were actually 270 thousand
which eventually got him to two hundred
seventy seven thousand from Google you
know I do not condone lying
that is extremely unethical so don't get
caught speaking of unethical and lying
Facebook is actually the worst place for
work-life balance according to our
survey I'm just kidding
I love Facebook Facebook is great love
the company love the people one of the
best cultures out there but there was a
thread on blind where they asked users
if they worked over 40 hours and if they
worked in during the weekend and
Facebook has the highest rate of 68
percent meaning 68 percent of them
reported working 40 hours or more
compared to Google which was 42 percent
46 percent reported working on weekends
for Facebook while Google only 19
percent I'm actually surprised LinkedIn
is there with 47 percent which surprised
me because when I was there they barely
worked weekdays and then question number
3 was do you feel pressure slash stress
due to fear of PIP which is a
performance improvement plan which means
you're gonna get fired soon or layoffs
of course number one was Netflix with
80% of the people
meaning everyone is scared shitless of
getting fired which is the line of what
I heard about the culture is that you
know they just fire people when they
don't need them but that's why your
products are so good
Amazon was 76% Facebook was 41% on a big
drop but it's still high compared to
Google with thirty thirteen percent and
Microsoft with seven percent honestly I
think a high layoff rate is actually
pretty good because it keeps their
employees on their toes I would hate to
have freeloaders and underperformers on
my team it's just not fun it drags you
down and I also love to gossip whenever
people are getting fired because that's
juicy [ __ ] of course these numbers are
not conclusive I mean the sample size is
extremely small and it's also biased I
know and I'm pretty good stats I mean
what can I say I was a data scientist
[Music]
now another thing I want to talk about I
want to talk about people complaining
about my ads in my videos now I want you
to know this is actually a very common
thing for youtubers to do and this
youtuber Dan mace explains it perfectly
before you start commenting are white
making an ad sponsored video you heard
to my eyes you're wasting my time let me
tell you something about sponsored
videos the brown doesn't have anything
to say over the actual content if
anything you should be stoked because
for me as a creator I'm getting paid in
order to make these films and in order
to make more phones I just have an
addiction like I can't stop myself you
know now I don't want to generalize
right but I'm pretty sure that most of
you if you were in my position like not
all but most of you would do the same if
you were my position would you put an ad
if they pay you $10,000 to do it not so
principled anymore aren't you dude I
would suck a dick for $10,000
just kidding just kidding I'd do it for
a hundred bucks but yeah I mean I
actually don't think that many people
are complaining I just really wanted to
say that joke was it funny okay whatever
in other news apparently Jacob Paul
dissed the whole software engineering
career there was a video of Jake Paul
wait let's see yeah a youtuber that
confronted this other youtuber his name
was Cody Coe and I'm actually a fan of
Cody cause I might be biased but Cody Co
made a funny commentary about him saying
I don't know like some criticism he made
another video where Jake Paul confronts
kotico to stop bullying stop internet
bullying when he described cody KO he
said that cody KO was just a small
back-end developer a back-end tech dude
I forgot what he said but here's the
clip I saw this is Cody kogai for the
first time when he was working at full
screen which is like a YouTube community
network as like a little backend tech
developer well he just single-handedly
disrespected a whole career saying that
or career software engineering is small
and no skill kind of a thing but it's
okay cuz at least Cody Cole has our back
just a little puny little back-end Tech
developer just so disrespectful
just belittling an entire career in one
little statement it's not cool dude you
can come for me as much as you want but
don't come from my fellow software
engineers that's where I draw the
[ __ ] line speaking of celebrities the
next story isn't about tech but it's
about constants boo actress from crazy
rich Asians she's also an actress from
an ABC show called fresh off the boat
and recently it got renewed so
apparently what happened is that on
Twitter she actually started saying
stuff like [ __ ] sake starts swearing
and expressing how much she was annoyed
by the show being renewed and people
were shocked about this now what
happened was she probably had a contract
that binded her in the show for like
maybe five years or six years I don't
know how many years but she would have
to continue filming for
fresh-off-the-boat but because of a
recent success of crazy rich Asians and
stuff like that she probably had better
opportunities coming in but she could
not take them she could not take them
more fulfilling job Rose because she has
to do
fresh off the boat so on Twitter she was
just saying like ah [ __ ] dis like I hate
that okay I forgot what she said exactly
but it was pretty disrespectful to the
show I think it's honestly fine to be
dissatisfied with something or like
dissatisfied with your current job if
you have better opportunities coming in
that's totally fine I understand that
but I think it's extremely disrespectful
to publicly curse your employers right I
mean is it an awkward if you go back to
work next year with the same employer
fresh off the boat and everyone knows
that you just hate your job like how are
you supposed to work with them now it's
terrible so I just want to end this
video by saying Constance that was an
extremely ungodly thing you did alright
peace came to chip and knuckle Phenom so
fitzy kept a weapon on me